Yeah, that's you reading Goypost chat
stressing out about people disagreeing
with him, man. You're on the panel, bro.
Pay attention to the panel. If you're If
you're looking out for yourself, if you
just want to protect your ethnicity,
it's fine to discriminate. Break up with
another man
and got totally mugged.
He's never recovered from it. He's
playing defense for lefties. He's on a
podcast with Pisco.
He's being mean to Hutch, so he deserves
it. He deserves it. Obviously the case.
So, for those who have not been
following, there's been a long-running
argument in uh both sort of like the
Destiny orbit and more broadly in uh
online politics about moderate libs
allying with people like Hasan, okay?
It's It really is all about Hasan. They
try and act like it's about other things
sometimes, but it always comes back to
Hasan and basically because of the
Israel issue. That's basically what the
whole thing's about. And that's been a
very long-running argument that a lot of
ex and
current Destiny orbiters and more
broadly libs online have been have been
having. But here, Soypill was initially
speaking to Wick, Kraut, and
ShortFatOtaku. And it was just those
four. But then Destiny and Erudite had
to had to come in and make sure everyone
was on track with hating Hasan. Make
sure everyone was still Hasan bad. And
we're going to skip most of it because
honestly, the first hour or two is not
that interesting. But in the second hour
of them being on, Destiny just starts
going crazy. Destiny and Erudite like
totally lose it and say some of the most
insane
you will ever hear from these people.
And I don't mean, you know, like it's
like Destiny talking about how
conservatives being fear after the
Charlie Kirk thing. It is like totally
incoherent with everything else you've
ever heard them say. So, we're going to
take a look. We're going to just see the
the sort of ending part of this and some
of Soypill's thoughts after and see what
we think. See what we think of that
their arguments here. Just take a look.
>> Obamacare to an extent, you know?
Just another Just another black creator
trying to steal from us whites again.
>> uh uh
True. They're getting mocked. I've got a
lot of love for God for the two Canadian
Wait, how does that If you think
Hassan's rhetoric is expressly
anti-Semitic,
then even further, how do you justify
working with him? Because the degree to
which he perpetuates it is masked enough
that I don't think it's the same type of
[__] that Nick Fuentes is doing. It's
still some [__] horrible. It's All
right. You can like every time you call
him out for his anti-Semitism, there's a
reason why his audience and anyone who
is a useful idiot will come and be like,
"Well, actually, I think he's just being
a little, you know, anti-Israel here." I
would just Soy Pill is like so close,
man. I would just love him to lay out
like the times Hassan's been
anti-Semitic, you know? I I haven't
heard him do that. I don't know what
we're calling anti-Semitic from Hassan.
I figure it's just like the clips of him
calling right-wing Israelis inbred.
That's probably That's probably what
they would point to, I would imagine, or
they would make some abstract argument
about how oh, he trivializes the lives
of Jews by downplaying October 7th, and
therefore he's I don't know, man. But
this still spreads like actual real
anti-Semitism, I'm sure, to like the
same kind of [__] you see that
But but
Oh, what?
Because I literally Because I can say
this is Wait, because I'm like this is
bad, but it's less harmful than explicit
anti-Semitism. It's more masked. Like,
yeah, like I'm sorry, it's just not as
bad. I don't know. I don't even know if
Hassan is masking. I'm not going to lie,
every time I tune into that
motherfucker's Do you think Do you think
the anti-Semitism that Hassan does,
which he absolutely does, and we're
acknowledging that, is just as bad as
Nick Fuentes's?
It's worse. It's worse. No, what? Nick
Fuentes is like, "Jews control the
world, and we need to kill them all."
This is what he's talking about. It's
obviously not the same.
No, that's not what he
Literally, go to the [__] you know,
go to the speech where he's got the big
screen behind him, and he's talking
about we need to like go to war with the
Jewish people. Like, what are you
talking about? You You know, you
understand why it's worse. Even if even
if Fuentes did say that, what Hassan is
doing is worse because it's normalizing
it and masking it, and it's much more If
you think that Nick Fuentes is If you
think that Nick Fuentes's audience is is
No, please wait. No, this is insane. If
you think that the people in Hassan's
audience, even the explicitly
anti-Semitic ones, No, answer my
question, wait, please.
No. No. No, that's so that's ridiculous.
It's so stupid. Because No, do you think
that Hassan's audience and and like per
capita is going to be more
pro-Holocausting the Jews than Nick
Fuentes' audience? No, no. I think I
think I think a lot of dude like saying
they would use different words, but yes.
He thinks that on average he thinks per
capita, okay,
Hasan fans are more likely
to
want to
Jew the Jews
than Nick Fuentes fans. They would just
say it differently.
You are so lost. You are so [__]
lost. You are either delusional or
lying. I honestly I think it's the
latter.
Honestly, I think it's the latter.
I think it's just lying.
I think all these people are very
spiteful, bitter people who feel locked
into a very bad position, and they're
very jealous of the fact there's this
massive content creator
that says different things to them
and kind of owns them pretty often, and
they're they're mad about it. And so
they lie about him. I I literally think
that's what's happening. Uh I would love
to Soy Pill seems like he's breaking the
conditioning. I would love to hear Soy
Pill's argument for why Hasan's
anti-Semitic. Why it's even like, you
know, it's laughable to bring up Hasan
in the same breath of Fuentes when it
comes to anti-Semitism. I'll hear you
out. I'll hear you out. Maybe he
disproportionately uses inbred for Jews.
I'll hear you out on that. Maybe he's
playing on some tropes there. Maybe he's
playing on some tropes when he calls
Asmongold Asmongoy. Maybe he's playing
on some tropes there. I'll hear you out
a bit there.
That's not the same as being an
ideological anti-Semite.
Nick Fuentes is a full-blown he's
ideologically anti-Semitic. It is a core
part of him that
there is a war against the Jews, a
spiritual war against the Jews that he
is fighting.
That's a core part of his beliefs.
Hasan doesn't think anything like that.
Not even remotely.
Not even close. You cannot even begin to
make the argument. It's like it's so
much worse. I don't care that they were
bad. This is so stupid. I'm not crossing
it because for the neo-Nazi position is
and has been, "Jews control all of our
country. We want all the Jews out. They
are in charge of things like great
replacement, etc." They but neo-Nazis
would never follow Jews to Israel. Hasan
advocates for a project of the
destruction of the state of Israel. He
would support military action to do it.
So, it's all about Israel. So, it's just
about Israel.
Hasan has no problem with Jews anywhere
else. He actually said the problem with
the state of Israel. But, that's
anti-Semitism.
Absurd. Totally [__] absurd.
I'm just saying Hasan would say, "Nuking
Israel is based." This is terrible. He's
[__] anti-Semitic.
Why is that anti-Semitic? Why is that
anti-Semitic?
Why is that anti-Semitic? Hasan doesn't
think nuking Israel would be based, by
the way. That's obviously not what Hasan
thinks. Let's say he does think
full-blown Vaush in his element glass
Israel.
How is that anti-Semitic? Please
explain.
Please, I would love to hear it.
It's like it's so much [__] worse.
Go ahead, Kraut. I genuinely believe
that Isaac's
I do genuinely believe that a
substantial amount of Hasan's audience
are just They would believe anything
that he tells them. That like if they
told him if he told them that this guy
is yellow, they would believe it is
yellow like that. I think a lot of his
audience are also just lonely horny
housewives, if that makes sense. Like I
It's debatable to what extent This is
Okay, if it's Nick Fuentes is a neo-Nazi
who says Jews have no place in
civilization and you're comparing this
to Hasan who is anti-Semitic, who is
conflating Israel and Judaism and is
saying a bunch of horrible [__] and
saying these things are worse than what
Nick Fuentes is saying, I don't know
what [__] reality we live in. This is
so like obviously
I don't know why I have to grade it,
though. I mean, they don't. They're both
bad. But, like
Hasan's The neo-Nazi anti-Semitism
doesn't extend past the borders of your
country. It's because Jews are
interested in destroying whatever the
fabric of your country through mass
migration or whatever else. But, Hasan's
anti-Semitism comes from an anti-Western
anti-imperialist place. He would follow
them to the Middle East where he would
want them to be removed from Israel.
That's why he Like you're never going to
hear from a neo-Nazi like, "Go back to
Brooklyn or whatever else." Right? If
anything, neo-Nazis would be happy if
every Jew [__] off to Israel. Whereas,
Hasan wants the country of Israel to be
destroyed. I think that that They
literally No, neo-Nazis are Zionists.
Neo-Nazis are also anti-Israel.
No, they're anti-America working with
Israel. No, they're so no. You're
thinking of like Christian nationalism
that are specifically looking at this.
But, they're so in Neo-Nazis [__]
hate Israel. What are you talking about?
Neo-Nazis talk When you say anti-Israel,
is Israel and its parts they exert
influence over the United States or
force the US to get involved with wars.
That's why they say like America first,
not Israel first, cuz Israel is making
us go to Yeah, but they also want to
kill all the Jews because of that. Like
that's what I'm saying. But why does
that matter if they're like, well, oh,
they want it if they if the Jews left
them alone. Yeah, but they think that
the Jews control everything and are
evil. Like what what what is this
distinction?
If we're not drawing a distinction
there, then then there's even less of a
distinction between Hassan's
perspective, which is that Zionism is
inherently like a What did he say on
CNN? Ethno-religious supremacist
nationalist project? Like and and 90% of
Jews are Zionists, so he would call for
basically the elimination of 90% of
Jewish people. Like what did he Hate.
So, let's try to run that back. Let's
hear the Let's hear the Let's hear the
steps here.
>> Israel first, cuz Israel is making us go
to war with Yeah, but they also want to
kill all the Jews because of that. Like
that's what I'm saying. But why does
that matter if they're like, well, oh,
they want it if they if the Jews left
them alone. Yeah, but they think that
the Jews control everything and are
evil. Like what what what is this
distinction?
If we're not drawing a distinction
there, then then there's even less of a
distinction between Hassan's
perspective, which is that Zionism is
inherently like a What did he say on
CNN? Ethno-religious supremacist
nationalist project? Like and and 90% of
Jews are Zionists, so he would call for
basically the elimination of 90% of
Jewish people. Like what did he say? The
he How does that follow?
So, Hassan says
Zionism is an ethno-nationalist, what
did he say, religious supremacist
project. Correct. Totally correct.
Absolutely true. Uncontestable,
inarguable statement that is just
absolutely true definitionally.
And so, 90% of Jews are Zionists.
And so, Hassan would call for the
elimination of 90% of Jews.
Hello?
Why did Hassan say
anyone who's an ethno-nationalist
religious extremist, uh religious
supremacist, sorry, should be
killed. When did Hassan say that?
When did Hassan say that ever?
He said you should not be allowed to
hold public office.
He said that.
He never said you should be killed.
Where is that? Please, I would love to
see it.
He before, what was it, 2 days ago? He
said they should all go back to the
Russian Oblast for Jews like way off in
the east like
I I don't know. Show me it. I'll I'll
I'll grade it I'll grade it next to the
Jews don't belong in Western
civilization and maybe they are cool.
This is why you can't make these
gambles, right? So the statement that I
just said, right? So like like um
Soy Poll's chat literally agrees with
this, right? How is that wrong? That's
true, right? So your chat even agrees
with these Yeah, because because it is
true. Yeah, it's because Soy Poll's chat
on apparently shockingly to me honestly
news to me Soy Poll's chat aren't
totally like bug broken.
So that they are they're able to hear
Destiny say a true thing in a strawman
voice and say wait, but that is true.
Wait, but
Wait, but you're you're saying something
true right now.
Yeah, that you're reading [__] Poll's
chat stressing out about people
disagreeing with him, man. You're on the
panel, bro. Pay attention to the panel.
How did he get away with this for so
long, dude? The guy's what are you going
to do with Zionism is an
ethno-supremacist religious-supremacist
project and if Is isn't Zionism
ethno-supremacist? No, it's not. Only if
your understanding of that is is is a
child's notion. Well, you've read a lot
more on Israel than I have. So I can't
say, but it seems to me that
Saying it's a supremacist is by
ethnically protecting a country is that
is it has to be an ethnically
supremacist position?
If you're If you're an ethno-state that
that treats them differently within your
society, I would say that's kind of
ethno-supremacist, yeah?
No, ethno-supremacist is different than
protecting the ethnicity of a country.
Well, you have in in protecting it,
you're expelling another peoples and
you're explicitly telling us to like get
all the Gazans out of the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip. This is
ethno-supremacist and
religious-supremacist.
If I can't I can't If that's your
perspective, then that's fine. There's
>> Well, tell me why it's not. I mean
that's how it sounds to me. It's not
about It's not about one religion
dominating another. It's about a people
having feeling like they want to protect
the ethnic group in their country. Yeah,
but but this is like oh yeah, they don't
want to expel black people. They just
want to protect the white population,
right? Like you can phrase it that way,
but like it seems to me that this is
prioritizing
Wait, white supremacists do you want to
chat
expel the Gazans and the Palestinians,
right? Like that's kind of their whole
mission. You don't have to expel you
don't have to expel black people in the
United States. There's no reason for
that. They're not a threat to the white
people. So it would make sense in that
sense. Whereas for the Middle East,
Jewish people are a huge minority in the
in the Middle East. So there's a
different Yeah, but now you're
justifying it. But it's that doesn't
mean it's not true. I'm just saying that
the the desire to protect the ethnicity
comes from a different place than
ethno-supremacy. It comes from a place
of there is an ethnicity that a country
wants to protect.
>> a distinction without a difference to
me. If you're having an ethno-fucking
position and expelling a bunch of people
that are of not of your ethnicity
because like well the well it's not
because I'm better than them. It's cuz
they're dangerous to me. Like oh well
black people commit too much crime.
That's the only reason I want to get
them out of guys. Like that's what it
sounds like to me.
If there was ethnic Jews in Israel, but
those ethnic Jews all flipped against
Israel and were also like working with
terrorist groups to attack Israeli
civilians, do you think Israel would
want them out? Yes, but that I don't
think that disproves what we're saying.
Well, it Okay, okay, let's run this
back. That doesn't mean it's not true.
I if that I can't I can't if that's your
perspective then that's fine. Well, tell
me why it's not. I mean if that's how it
sounds to me. I told you. It's not about
it's not about one religion dominating
another. It's about a people having
feeling like they want to protect the
ethnic group in their country. Yeah, but
but this is like oh yeah, they don't
want to expel So dude, that is literally
what any white nationalist would say.
Destiny has spent
years arguing
with retards on the kill stream and all
this [__] about great replacement, Wosky
live, whatever.
Arguing against that [__] And then he
just makes the exact same argument for
Israel. It's literally it is verbatim
the exact same argument.
protecting it. You're expelling another
people from their
No, it's not. Only if your understanding
of that is is is a child's notion.
>> Well, you've read a lot more on Israel
than I have, so I can't say, but it
seems to me that
>> it's not saying it's a supremacist is by
ethnically protecting a country is it is
it has to be an ethnically supremacist
position?
Yes, if you're if you're an ethno-state
that purges all non-Jews out of your
area and then treats them differently
within your society
>> yes, so I supremacist. The answer is
just yes.
>> is different than protecting the
ethnicity of a country. Well, you have
in in protecting it you're expelling
another peoples and your explicit
mission is to like get all the Gazans
out of the West Bank and the Gaza Strip.
This is ethno-supremacist and religion
supremacist.
We got that?
If that I can't I can't if that's your
perspective then that's fine. Well, tell
me I know you've got no response.
He has no response. How is this working
out at this point? Who is buying what
this [__] idiot is selling at this
point? This [__] stupid parlor. It's
got to only be Israelis, right? Israelis
and Indians. That's all that can It can
only be Israelis and Indians.
They they have to want to believe it.
Like who else is buying this truly?
It's not about one religion dominating
another. It's about a people having
feeling like they want to protect the
ethnic group in their country. Yeah, but
but this is like oh yeah, they don't
want to expel black people. They just
want to protect the white And Japan is a
racist country. What do you mean?
population, right? Like you can phrase
it that way, but like it seems to me
that this is
prioritizing my people.
Yeah, and and Zionists want to expel the
Gazans and the Palestinians, right? Like
that's kind of their whole mission.
No, it's not.
people in the United States. There's no
reason for that. They're not a threat to
the white people. So, it wouldn't make
sense in that sense. Whereas in the
Middle East Jewish people are a huge
minority in the in the Middle East. So,
there's a different rational
>> but now you're justifying it, but it's
that doesn't mean it's not true.
desire to protect the ethnicity comes
from a different place than
ethno-supremacy. It comes from a place
of there's an ethnicity that a country
wants to protect.
>> This is a distinction without a
difference. Dude, what is the
difference? Your ethnicity will
disappear if there's too much
immigration and and racial mixing,
right? So, why is it white supremacist
for someone in the United States to say,
"I want to protect my ethnicity. Let's
stop letting in so many [__] Mexicans
and deport some of them that are here."
What's the problem?
Well, what is your argument against that
now?
Because I would just say
it's on principle wrong to discriminate
along ethnic lines. You shouldn't People
are individuals. You know, you can draw
statistical inferences about groups, but
you shouldn't hold people personally
responsible for the generalities of the
group they belong to. They're an
individual. Because that's That's the
liberal perspective. I thought that was
the liberal perspective. Now, these
liberals apparently disagree. These
liberals think that if you're if you're
looking out for yourself, if you just
want to protect your ethnicity, it's
fine to discriminate. It's fine to
discriminate. So, what's your argument
against any white nationalist?
What is your argument against any white
white nationalist? How do you even begin
to combat that?
So, if you're having an pro-ethno
[__] position and expelling a bunch
of people that are of not of your
ethnicity because like, "Well, the Well,
it's not because I'm better than them.
It's cuz they're dangerous to me." Like,
"Well, black people commit too much
crime. That's the only reason I want to
get them out, guys." Like, that's what
it sounds like. Like, for real. If there
was ethnic Jews in Israel, but those
ethnic Jews all flipped against Israel
and were also like working with
terrorist groups to attack Israeli
civilians, do you think Israel would
want them out? In the same way that they
want black people That's literally
describing people taking an actual
hostile action.
And you would I don't like I don't know
how it citizenship and stuff works in
Israel, but as a liberal, yeah, you
should be against someone who's a
citizen in the country being like
denaturalized and deported for being a
terrorist. Yeah, actually Erudite, as a
liberal, you should be against that, you
[__] idiot.
Yeah, they would they would want them
gone, but it would be principally wrong
to No, they should be given a prison
sentence. Right?
[__] idiot.
This proves what we're saying.
Well, it it Well, potentially in this
case, right? They might be willing to
like
>> They'd be like, "Oh, you're something."
Yeah, in the same way a neo-Nazi would
be like, "You're a traitor, you white
that's willing to work with the
minorities, and you've betrayed your
country and your people." It's like,
yeah, but I don't think that means
they're not a white supremacist. Like,
this is a very
>> Okay. Okay, we can have we can have this
Israel debate another day. Uh $5 Well,
you have to establish a Jew think that
they're better, not that they're like
worried about like safety or something.
For the which they do.
In Israel.
>> So, this is the By definition, Judaism
is not like a it's not a proselytizing
religion. They don't even try to convert
people into their [__] [__] or
whatever. What the [__] do they How is
that responsive? How is that responsive
at all?
Dude.
Jews in Israel don't think they're
better than anyone else. They don't
proselytize. How is that responsive in
any way? Sorry, how are you even trying
to pass this off as like
a reputation?
They're constantly trying to do this
[__]
They're not trying to convert people to
Judaism.
>> literally exactly not that. Birthright
is not
>> Yeah, they want them to come in and
>> They want people that already belong to
the ethnicity to become more religious
and become committed to Israel and the
Zionist project. That's That's what they
want. That's the conversion they do.
Thank you for the $5, Samson. Thank you.
Highly appreciate it. Thank you for the
$10, Doobie. Thank you.
>> understand how they justify this in
their brains. It's like the liberal
values they rage at Trump for violating
just vanish from I don't think they even
bother. I don't think they even bother.
I think they just know they're lying at
this point, frankly.
I I
don't I I literally see no other way to
rationalize this.
They try to and they try to make them
more culturally Jewish and more
religiously Jewish, like What do you
think birth What does the birth part in
birthright stand for? Yeah, I know that
they're They're Jewish by blood, but
they want them to become more religious.
That's like a dude, come on. Like you're
Jewsplaining to me. This is what they
[__] do. Yeah, not just join the
country. They want to indoctrinate into
the culture and the [__] religion.
They do this.
>> Jewsplaining, it's goysplaining. They're
goysplaining to you. They're
goysplaining.
Best you get on stream [__]
goysplaining you again.
All the time.
This is a left wing point. No, dude.
Just listen. No, no. Don't want to hear
it. Don't want to hear it.
They pay people to go to synagogue in
Israel and even here because they want
them to become part of this Jewish
cultural movement. This is just a thing.
I'm not even saying this is a bad thing
cuz the idea that they're not promoting
their religion is ridiculous. Of course
they do this.
>> is to bring Jews back to Israel so that
they can shore up their demographic
majority so that they can absorb more
Arabs than they have to.
>> Yes, it is. I'm not disagreeing with
this. This is how they do it.
This is not even Oh, yeah. Wait, wait.
Sorry, it's just Sorry, they want more
Jews in Israel to shore up their
majority in case they have to bring in
more Arabs. Is that Is that really why
they want more Jews in Israel? That's
why Netanyahu wants more Jews in Israel.
Not because they want to expand.
Because they want to expand. Not because
they want they want their country to be
bigger and to expand outwards, but
because they want to
what because they want to have more
Arabs there. Not because they want to
kill everyone on the borders and slowly
expand with buffer zones in South
Lebanon and No, no, of course not. Of
course not. They do that. They promote
this as well as part of Birthright. They
literally promote religious teachings.
Okay. This is just true. I don't know
why you're arguing with this. Hold on.
You guys can debate this another day. $5
from Grandman for the two Canadians. So,
this is to Dev and to Araydi.
Who do you think is more extreme? Hassan
or Avi Lewis, the new head of the
federal NDP in terms of
>> How can he say they don't care about the
religion when Jews who convert to
Christianity lose access to Birthright?
>> Well, obviously they do. Obviously they
do. It doesn't make any None of it makes
any sense. He doesn't care. He's just
lying.
He's just lying cuz he's mad that Hassan
is winning and he's stuck in a [__]
position where he's tied himself to an
ever more unpopular
uh political position.
That's what it's all about. That's what
it all is.
There's literally there is no other way
to explain what's happening here.
The policy and how they act. I don't
know anything
>> Thank you for the $10 David. We really
appreciate it.
>> he's fighting with the Alberta people,
but I don't know anything about Avi
Lewis, frankly. I can't answer this,
sorry.
I think I care about Canadian politics.
Well,
to be honest, the NDP is just [__]
irrelevant. Hassan is probably more
irrelevant than anything happening with
the NDP in total. Yeah, he's probably a
bigger
existential threat to democracy than
Avi.
I would assume. I don't know who the I
yeah, I don't know anything about him.
>> Hassan is an existential threat to
democracy.
>> euros from Avi from Saxon to say Avi
Lewis for the win.
Uh Lex loves Wick, question mark. Okay.
$5 from straight shot. Can any of the
panelists name an anti-Zionist that also
happens to be a liberal?
Tony Judt. Like such an absurd question.
How much Like how badly do you need to
have
Yankee brain rot to genuinely ask this
question? You have to be legitimately
the most American [__] loser in the
world to to genuinely ask the question,
"Uh can you even name a single
anti-Zionist liberal?"
Yeah, like literally everyone outside of
your country. Literally every liberal
outside of your [__] [__] country.
[__]
anti-Zionist, I think, but it sounds
like that's like a poison word now.
Maybe I don't fully understand it, but
>> like
I I don't Like anti-Zionist is a is is a
mask word in a lot of ways. But Tony
Tony Judt was sort of to correct me. So,
Tony Judt was more of a social democrat,
but he was anti-Zionist
democratic liberal wing, I guess. I mean
you could take the position that
nationalism is
>> Uh Mehdi Hasan's a tankie because he
insulted Destiny on Twitter.
Bad.
And in particular the European liberal
position that nationality should become
a choice. That what nationality you are
should be as simple as learning a
language.
And from that perspective you can make
an anti-Zionist liberal case,
definitely. Yeah.
That was hilarious. I don't know if you
guys saw that, but there was like this
Twitter exchange where Destiny
quote-tweeted Emma Vigeland saying,
"You're not on our team."
And then Mehdi Hasan replies going,
"What team is that? Starving Palestinian
children to death?"
Says for $5, are liberals able to assert
that people who immigrate to Western
countries should assimilate to the
culture of said country, language,
beliefs, etc.?
Yes, it's preferable.
To to to to some level, yeah, I think
so.
Yeah, it's just like what a liberal
means when they say assimilate is
different
What a what a like a MAGA groper means
when they say assimilate and what a like
a left liberal means when they say
assimilate. It's just like obviously not
the same thing, so Yeah, and on that I
have more in common with an illegal
immigrant who doesn't speak English but
came to California than I do with a
[__] MAGA groper in like Tennessee.
So like uh it depends on what level of
assimilation we're looking for. I think
that yeah, there should be a place that
Jews call their home given the fact that
they're kicked out of [__] everywhere
and there's anti-Semitism everywhere.
But the idea that the only solution to
this is to establish in this historical
homeland that is never ever going to be
solved. It's constantly going to be
having war fought back and forth.
>> basically says that Israel shouldn't be
in the Levant. That's like his That's
kind of like you know what I'm saying.
play
Obviously what I mean is the project of
Zionism to establish it in Israel. And
the way that they did this I think was
destructive as [__] I think it's led to
all these problems. I I think they
should have chosen something different
at the time. And so the idea What? When
you're saying anti-Zionist as in you
don't want them to be the majority in
their country anymore. So then what is
that Is that Is that what anti-Zionism
is? I'm not saying that they can't be
the majority unless
being the majority in their country
Zionism is where you have a Jewish
majority in Israel because it's an
ethno-protected majority. it is. if the
way that if the way that you are
establishing this ethnic majority is
that you expel minorities and like steal
their land and kill people, yeah.
>> So, little thing there is uh
I think um
who uses the [__] definition of
Zionism where it's just if you believe
Israel in some form should exist.
Because Destiny here is saying that it
requires the principal commitment to an
ethnic majority, right?
That's what That's what he's saying. But
I think I feel like did Lone Wolf Box
use some other definition? I don't
remember. And I'm I'm anti that. So,
hold on that. We're still doing it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, because nobody
ever has to answer this question and
they'll never they say they're
anti-Zionists. So, it's I know why, but
I'm just curious. Like what So, what is
the solution then? It's the map of the
Israel.
It's the Okay, so the Are you giving me
the dichotomy between the same First of
all, the idea that I can solve this with
Palestine is ridiculous cuz I'm [__]
[__] But second of all, you're
asking me No, No, Zoabox is back to
streaming now. Zoabox is back to
streaming. He still hasn't responded to
Chad's offer to moderate a conversation.
But hey, who knows? Who knows? Maybe
he'll respond. Maybe he'll respond. You
give me the dichotomy. If you're asking
me the dichotomy between what they're
doing in the West Bank and Gaza and not
doing that, I think there's probably a
better thing to do. And just because I
don't know exactly what they should do
doesn't mean I'm anti-Jew or
anti-fucking like [__] pro-ethnic
cleansing.
Using it's an ethno-protected majority
to avoid saying ethno-state is
hilarious.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. To enforce ethnic majority is an
ethno-state. That's what you want an
ethno-state is.
It's just so [__] stupid. That's why
I hate that the whole leftist people
have decided to purity test on this one
issue because the position is totally
untenable. No, no, I'm not saying you
are, but all the other people that you
listen to or that are on the far left
they purity test on this position. Like
when somebody says they're anti-Zionist,
I just don't know what that means. What
does it actually I'm I'm anti-Israel's
project of ethnically cleansing Gazans
right now.
Okay. Let me just say
>> If they stopped that's Zionism. Hold on.
This seems to be in the name of Zionism.
stopped in the West Bank, but still kept
their
uh their ratios for how many ethnic Jews
are in the country versus how many
other ethnicities are in the country,
you'd be okay with that? Uh if how do
they enforce their ethnic ratios?
By only letting in
ethnic Jews and expelling if it goes
above a certain amount the uh How would
How is Oh, you would be okay with this.
You're a liberal, you [__] [__]
Because
the thing
is
That's what I think cleansing is
necessarily bad. I think we should
ethnically cleanse Turkish people from
West Hollywood personally. I don't think
all ethnic
To be fair, I know that was a meme, but
do you actually
>> Isn't this wretched Pova so funny and
how his entire life is dictated by his
hatred of this one guy who totally
mugged him?
One guy who totally mugged him. He's
actually never recovered from this one
guy breaking up with him.
Break up with another man. And then got
totally mugged.
He's never recovered from it. It
dictates his entire life to the point
where he nuked his political career over
it.
Well, that and the impulse control
issues that led to him sharing his
friends' sexual images without consent.
Also obviously did not help him.
Like when when is ethnic cleansing
justified? Like Chinese exclusion act
type stuff or like like oh, we can only
have this ratio of like this type of
people in this country. Is it ever
justified?
It probably Yeah, probably is.
>> Never. It's never. It's never justified.
The reason why
The reason why it's hard to have this
conversation as an American is because
we get to take our ethnicity or national
identity for granted because we're never
threatened by anybody because we have
way too many [__] people. So, it's
not a question for us. But if we had
countries to the north If Canada had 10
billion
>> What What do you mean? Your ethnic
majority is threatened.
With enough time, immigration will
threaten your ethnic majority. That's
just You know, they're right about the
demographic projections, right?
When white nationalist say that [__]
the facts of the demographic projections
That's true.
The issue is the prescription.
But you don't have an issue with the
prescription.
So what's your issue with that?
people in Mexico had 30 billion people,
we would be having questions about what
the American ethnicity is and how we
need to protect it all the time. The
American ethnicity? What do you What are
we saying now, dude? just get a bunch
more Canadians and Mexicans and this
transforms our country, then so be it.
Every single person just does Why
wouldn't you Okay, so every single
person in Canada, every single person in
Canada, every single person in Mexico is
a Nazi. And we lived in the United
States of America and we had 300 million
people. Let's say that 500 million Nazis
from Canada wanted to immigrate into the
United States. You would accept that
unquestionably. I wouldn't promote I
wouldn't promote an ethnic cleansing.
No, I wouldn't. And yeah, if I think we
have a far different problem if you have
an ideology so pervasive that it's going
to destroy your entire democracy and
coming at like people you're you're
sounding like the [__] people talking
about No, no, no, no. You're talking
like the people talking about Okay,
Muslims Muslims are coming into this
country. Muslims want to destroy the
democracy, so we should ethnically
cleanse Muslims from Europe. Is that
what you're supporting?
There's millions. But there's millions
of them. There's tens of millions going
to Germany.
What about Germany? Should Germany
ethnically cleanse Muslims from their
population of I'm pretty willing to bet
you said it's justified. It's 80 million
people plus 14 million Syrian refugees
coming in, right?
What about another If there were If
there were 10 billion Muslims to the
north that wanted to destroy democracy
in America and 500 million wanted to
immigrate, I think I would have some
questions about that. I think most
reasonable people would. We don't have
to worry about that. There are 7 million
Jews in in Israel in a in a region
surrounded by a billion Arab/Muslims.
They do have another question about
that. A lot of these Arab majority
states literally have their ethnic
identity protected in the constitution,
but they just don't deal with them as
much cuz there's not a billion Chinese
people trying to immigrate to [__]
Pakistan.
You can be against that. You can be
against that.
Okay. You can be against it, but it
doesn't matter that you're against it.
Yeah, it's like
They don't have a forced ethnic majority
of [__] no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Soy pill, soy pill, the law prevents
rich people and poor people alike from
stealing a loaf of bread, right? That
law's obviously going to only affect the
poor people in a realistic sense. What
you have to engage with and what
anti-Zionists have to engage with and
they're, you know, I I'm not asking you
to solve Israel-Palestine, but if these
protections for the ethno-state, and it
is an ethno-state, of
Israel went away,
they would be under massive threat.
>> Right. And if you're if you're giving me
the trolley problem of either support
ethnic cleansing or your country is
taken over by neo-Nazis, like yeah, I
guess, but like I don't know But it's
just such a easy
thing to thing to reconcile here. Just
Yeah, I don't think that Israel should
just open their borders indiscriminately
to anyone in neighboring countries right
now.
But they should drop the principal
commitment to an ethnic majority and
move towards a direction where legally
everyone's one person, one vote. It's
not an apartheid state. No one's getting
[__] set in their houses settled. No
one's, you know, getting different
punishments under the law, you know,
there's all this insane [__] like death
penalties for only Palestinians and all
this crazy [__] Obviously, that's the
direction they should move in. They
should move away from enforcing an
ethnic majority, away from enforcing
one-sided rules
and into being an actual liberal
democracy
that accepts people of all all
backgrounds.
That that's obvi- obviously what you
should say here.
What you should think as a liberal.
That's easy for you to say. Is your
country threatening
the majority with bloodthirsty Muslims?
Uh how do I answer that question? Do I
answer that question seriously or not?
Cuz it's not funny to answer that
question seriously. You know how you map
this onto reality when there are
potentially infinite solutions in
between those of making a project that
doesn't involve ethnic cleansing that
solves this and going to extreme
hypotheticals of yeah, if there were 10
billion Nazis in Canada and they're all
coming in, well, yeah, obviously I don't
want Nazis in my [__] country. This
would suck. But but but the idea that
like, okay, therefore you support ethnic
cleansing was like this isn't what we're
talking about necessarily. We're talking
about specific situations that Okay, go
ahead.
You're saying support extreme
hypotheticals like Hamas is not an
organization that was supported by
Hezbollah that lived to the north of
Israel that was supported by Iran that
was the basically the largest player in
the region that was tangentially
peripherally supported by the Houthis.
Like
what you're like hypothetically
hypothetically like I can never even
imagine this to be the case. But this is
like the reality.
>> the hypothetical is either you
ethnically cleanse or you die.
No, the the
>> That's the hypothetical you gave me,
right? Either you either ethnically
cleanse all these Nazis out or you die.
Why are you just why are you just
filibustering? The hypothetical was do
you protect the ethnic majority of your
country or do you become an ethnic
minority and then die? That's the
hypothetical. Okay. So, using this
logic, should Germany expel all the
Syrians?
How many Syrians
>> Like 10 to 14 million. And then 80
million
>> No, there's a million. There's only a
million wasn't it 10 to 14 million in
the call that you No, it's a million. I
think it's probably the full Syrian
refugee crisis number, right? 10 to 14
million, but Germany probably has like a
million.
I think I think Striker's talking up
bit.
But it's not the point anyway. You can
just use Muslims broadly. You can just
use Muslims broadly. The argument works,
you know. They're not talking about any
specific country.
Yeah, obviously a lot of it's going to
be Palestinians, but
there's there's neighboring Arab
countries that Muslims may want to
immigrate from. I mean, they probably
wouldn't to be honest. They probably
want to stay in their own country. They
probably won't want to go to Israel.
But, you know, that
theoretically
Yeah, yeah, 1.5 million.
That makes sense.
Wasn't it like 14 million
like the entire Syrian diaspora?
>> Okay, maybe I'm mixing up the numbers.
Let's say it's a million in Germany out
of a population of 80 million. Is that
Is that too many? You left this tactic.
No, I I was just wrong. I'm admitting
that. I got the number mixed up. If it's
a million in 80 million, should they
start ethnically cleansing them if more
and more people are coming and they're
subverting the
>> Muslims. Just use Muslims. Just use Just
talk about how you know it's going to be
white Germans are going to be an ethnic
minority
by whatever year.
What's the problem with that?
What's the problem if Germans want
Germany for for the Germans, you know?
What's the problem with that?
They want They just want to maintain
their ethnic majority. What's the
problem? They want to protect their
ethnicity.
Big [__] deal.
No, it won't get to that point because
those countries protect their
immigration. They don't accept that many
people. So, they don't get to that
point.
Just look at look at the demographic
projections through race mixing, through
immigration,
the the the white native
population will become a minority.
That's just the case.
That is just the case.
But, what's the problem with that?
What's your prescription?
Reason why like in part we're super
concerned about Muslims is that they
are not a dichotomy between ethnic
cleansing and death.
>> Yes, yes, no, I agree because they
protect their immigration and they die
in a certain space and time. Yes. That's
what That's the dichotomy because for
the one staters, for all the lefties out
there I've never watched this much of
Destiny debating. Does he always bug out
like this? It's so emotional. Uh
yeah, the last like
three or four years, yeah, this is
pretty normal. And they want Israel to
be
>> this is actually quite uh collected for
Destiny these days. single state that
accepts every single Palestinian as an
Israeli citizen and then all of the
diaspora Palestinians as Israeli
citizens so that the Jewish people will
be like 30% of the population there.
Okay, so they will vote to have a that
will likely want to expel all the
>> me through this then.
I oppose Israel's ethnic cleansing.
I acknowledge that there is a world in
which the population gets to a point
where Israel would the Jews in Israel
would be ethnically cleansed by the
population that hates them that they
allowed in. That both of these things
are like potentially completely
plausible, right?
Why is it bad for me to oppose the
ethnic cleansing if I believe there
could be, even if I can't give you the
solutions, ways to get around this that
are not let's just keep ethnically
cleansing people and supporting
ethno-supremacist state.
>> If you have a better solution, I'm all
ears. Well, the issue is that people
seem to be hardcore against the Zionist
project. So you call yourself an
anti-Zionist, but then the what the on
the flip side of that, if you if the
anti-Zionist were to have it their way,
you'd probably see, my guess is another
like mass expulsion, mass
if not a genocide, then at least some
kind of mass ethnic cleansing of the
Israeli state. But I don't think anybody
would be any of the pro-Palestinian
people are not going to stand up to say
anything about that. So they're
basically just like This is expelling
from their country. Sure, but this is
why it's frustrating because the project
of Zionism said, "We're going to
establish this country here." and it
caused all these downstream effects that
are now putting us in this position
where in a between a rock and a hard
place. And I'm saying, "This [__]
position sucks. I hate that you are now
making me choose between ethnic
cleansing or not and death of every Jew
or ethnic cleansing of of Israel and all
the Jews out of Israel and therefore I
oppose the project that established it
this way and such a way that It's just
like what happened during the war. Like
No, no one is saying you can't say that.
That doesn't mean you oppose the
project. That means that you oppose the
state of Israel today. But I still do
because of the way they're doing it.
Like it's like, yeah, I don't think this
is like, okay, is the solution just
forever we're going to be this you know
ethnically cleansing thing and we'll
never ever not be at war with everyone
around us. Like I don't know what the I
don't know what the solution is today,
but when when lefties say that they
oppose Israel, they oppose Israel with
their chest. They want to defund it.
Maybe they want military action for
regime change there. That's their type
of opposition. But if Arabs were to
become the majority in the state of
Israel and then were to start massively
expelling Jewish people, I don't think
lefties would have [__] to say about it.
I would also have a problem with ethnic
cleansing. If I were to use chat GPT
like smash saying stop being PC about
Palestine.
Dude, posting like the uh she's running
the um
Brianna Wu
just uh just saw some Palestinian kids
stone a dog to death tweet through like
a
chat GPT be like, this is what they're
like. This is what they're like.
I saw the October 7th videos. Yeah, you
you can't stop me. Haha. You can't stop
me. Haha.
If Arabs did it to Jews, so I
>> That's what That's fine.
>> as if the Zionist project right now
though is
>> There is just such a horrendous image,
isn't it? Brianna Wu
like 6'3 ghoulish figure
she looming over you like the [__]
Addams Family looming over this group of
like
little brown Palestinian kids.
They're like [__]
like
six or seven years old, rags
dirt all over their face, rubble
everywhere. They're like traumatized.
They're like They're pelting stones at a
dog.
Disgusting. Disgust She spits at them.
So I get her phone out. Just saw some
Palestinian kids stone a dog to death.
Savages.
Oh my god.
It's brilliant.
The end. And you know, I correct me if
I'm wrong, ethnic cleansing
>> They just like look at They look up.
They look up from stoning the dog. They
just shriek and run away. They shriek
and run away. It's the most Yeah,
they've just survived bombing campaign.
Seen their families die.
Brianna Wu's ghoulish figure is just the
most terrifying thing they've ever laid
eyes upon. This is a horror they can't
comprehend. Did the what? The Zionist
project necessitates ethnic cleansing
right now. It cannot exist without them
continuously ethnically cleansing
people.
It depends on if you consider the
existence of Palestinian You guys are
going to be like what type of dog is
that?
Technically, it depends right now on an
on an indefinite
occupation of the West Bank and the Gaza
Strip. Occupation, ethnic cleansing,
kicking people out based on their race.
>> Yeah, she was in Israel.
>> people out, but keeping them in the West
Bank and the Gaza Strip. Okay. There's 2
million Arabs that live in Israel proper
that like that aren't in the West Bank
or the Gaza Strip.
Yeah.
That that they're not getting kicked out
of Israel. Okay. Gang. So, Phil, can I
ask you one last question? Mhm. If the
people wanting to come into your country
>> Like dude, legit, dude, this image has
been sent. Dude, dude, dude. Imagine the
[__] Palestinian kids seeing this.
Dude, imagine some [__] Gazan kids
seeing this [__] What the [__] They
would have no [__] idea what they're
looking at. They would have no [__]
idea what they're looking at. They're
genuinely terrified. They're genuinely
like world-shaking like
what the [__] is that?
Or they're just screaming and just
shrieking and running away.
political power in your country all want
to kill you.
And you if you don't want those people
around, is that supremacist?
Um if you're doing it on a race-based
like
uh
a discrimination thing, like yeah, it's
like yes, but no. If you're just like
hey, well, I I don't know. Do we
ideologically test people that come in?
>> ethnic groups wanting to move in want to
kill you? Dude, yeah, super solid.
dominant ethnic groups. Is that
supremacist? Uh in this very specific um
Well, wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. That's supremacist? French toast.
This is a Okay, this is huge.
Uh occupation of the West Bank and the
Gaza Strip.
>> Occupation, ethnic cleansing, kicking
people out based on their race.
Not kicking people out, but keeping them
in the West Bank and the Gaza Strip.
Okay. There's 2 million Arabs that live
in Israel proper that like that aren't
in the West Bank or the Gaza Strip.
Yeah.
That that they're not getting to get out
of Israel. Okay. Gang. So, Phil, can I
ask you one last question? Mhm. If the
people wanted to come into your country
or like have political power in your
country, all want to kill you, and you
if you don't want those people around,
is that supremacist? So, literally, this
is a liberal saying,
"People are individuals. Actually,
they're members of homogeneous ethnic
groups that have a single-minded focus
on one ideology, one religion
to a fundamentalist degree, and they
will and and they're all racist, and
they want to kill everyone of this other
race."
So, I thought we were liberals over
there. I thought that's what was going
on here. I thought this this whole panel
was was a bunch of liberals. I thought
that's what
I was watching here.
Apparently not.
Or it's not the case. Apparently, they
believe in racial essentialism.
And they think that you can categorize
and discriminate in law
against people of other ethnic groups,
and that's that's totally legitimate and
not uh principally wrong.
So, we're just totally [__] lost at
this point. Hassan hysteria is at new
levels, guys. What's Lauren Southern
take on this on this uh
awesome restore Britain-esque argument?
I would love to hear. I would love to
see Lauren Southern watch this panel and
go, "Ah.
Ah, the thing the thing leftists just
don't understand is Jews are just
different to us. They just get to have
their own rules, do whatever they want,
okay? So, you need to just stop
criticizing Jews
cuz the Holocaust.
Ah.
Don't you know anything about the
history of Jews?"
Um if you're doing it on a race-based
like
uh
I mean uh it's discrimination thing,
like yeah, like yes, but no. But it's
just
>> Stress I
>> Hey, well, I I don't know. Do we
ideologically test people coming in?
>> dominant ethnic groups want to kill you?
So, you don't want any of those dominant
ethnic groups.
>> wait. Like
uh
my
it's discrimination thing like yeah,
it's like yes, but no if you're just
like
Hey, well I I don't know. Do we
ideologically test people who come in?
>> ethnic groups wanting to move in want to
kill you? So you don't want any of those
dominant ethnic groups. Is that
supremacist?
>> in this very specific um
this hypothetical, technically yes
because by necessity your race is the
one that doesn't want to kill your race
and your race is better, but not in the
same way that it's like I think white
people are superior to black people.
Wait, you you decided that your race is
better is not them being supremacist.
That's kind of you being supremacist,
right?
No, but yeah, if you think every other
race is awful and they all want to kill
me, I'm the good one, then I like it
just by necessity is supremacist, right?
Dev, what did you want?
Earlier. Oh, he muted himself.
>> even recall anymore, man. Sorry. Sorry,
Bill. I'll just correct that or that
sounds totally [__] deranged. And
she's got no response.
She has no response. So many times have
Destiny and Erudite you just left with
no response.
So if you're just like, "Oh, no, that is
actually ethnic supre-
ethno-supremacist."
And they're like
They're like Oh.
I I guess it must be your perspective or
Erudite just shuts up. Erudite just
stops talking. Erudite just shuts down.
Man, sorry. Okay. Okay, we are we are
going to wrap this up a little soon cuz
I got to eat and do something. Oh no, I
got I got it now. I got it back. Wait,
okay.
Crow, I think you know more about this
than me, so just fill me in real quick.
Um wasn't there a project in the Soviet
Union to make like an alternate Israel
in the Far East of Russia?
>> is typically referring to like
when they're using it in this context
anyway, like
you know, there's there's ideological
supremacist where it's like I'm better
than you. But the way they're using it
here is supremacy in in like law, right?
It's about policy. They enforce it as
white supremacy. And if a black person
says, "All white people are racist."
Um
they're probably racist themselves, but
all people are racist, you know? All
people are racist.
So, it's not really saying anything.
It's not really saying anything.
I am. Nice. Okay.
Oh, yeah, that was a failure. Project to
make them? You mean a place where they
were all like shoot off to? That they
all left as soon as the Iron Curtain
fell? I mean
Sure. Yeah, probably. 5 bucks No, I I I
I just I I I recall that they they they
sent out like
>> The The thing You mean the thing that we
talked about uh a few a year ago or so?
Because the thing that I'm did was like
anti-Semitism in communist regimes.
And most of what I studied was like
Czechoslovakia and Poland. So, just uh
quickly
There's a final part to the soy pill
stuff.
Soy pill
after uh the debate we just watched some
of
uh talks with stream chat a little bit.
Reflects on the arguments he was hearing
from uh Destiny and Erudite. So, let's
just quickly hear what he's got to say
about that.
for productivity. And it's like, "Okay."
But Anyway, thanks for being here, Soy
Pill. Appreciate you hopping on. Love
you, baby. Bye. Dev last
All right, guys. Um
I can't wait until we do I'm not even
reading out the rest of that message.
This guy gay as hell.
Um um um um um
That was wild. I don't know. I don't
know if Destiny and Erudite are just
being contrarian, but correct me if I'm
wrong. That's just felt like
I felt like they were giving me like
white nationalist as talking points, but
like in defense of Israel. And it's
like, "Okay, like So
how is that not just true?
Erudite literally sounded like a restore
supporter, man. Literally, she sounded
like any
far right
loser.
Just about Israel. She's about the Jews.
I What the [__] Like, you know, you can
be
you can be pro like I don't want to
ethnically cleanse. Like
[__] Israel without saying like, oh,
like necessity. It's a necessity that we
do this or we'll die. And it's like, is
it? Are there no other solutions? Can we
do nothing else? Like and if it is, like
I
I we need to do something about it. Like
and it seems like the the only
prescription is I don't have a solution.
We just have to do this like
indefinitely. And
I don't know, man. Oh, that's not what I
wanted. How do I flip horizontally?
I'm a gay man with no or hesitating
>> know how to flip horizontally. normalize
trans in this. Wait. Oh, transform.
>> That wasn't the part of the message that
I was calling gay.
Um Dryand 5, God designers and the Dems
are so insufferable supporting a state
that violates human rights. Oh, great
question in chat here. Aside from
donating, well, you should donate if you
can, but you're saying obviously you
can't, but I'm just reminding people
they can. In fact, let's just talk about
the ways to support me. Guys, it's an
authoritarian ethnostate is misguided.
Yeah, and it's like
it's like, oh, if you don't support it,
you want to ethnically cleanse Israel,
right? Because you realize that like by
existing there, they're always going to
be doing this. And I'm like, well,
no, I don't want to ethnically cleanse
Israel, but I also think the manner in
which they're maintaining their state in
the name of Zionism is bad. And I don't
know how to stop that. And and I I would
prefer if there was like more
integration. And I think there could be
like a idea of a one state with
assimilation. And if you're saying
that's impossible, then what you're
telling me is that it it necessitates
perpetual ethnic cleansing. And the only
way this can stop suffering is if we
take a bunch of the people and just move
them somewhere else, which is ethnic
cleansing. That's like the ultimate
ethnic cleansing or final solution, if
you will. And it's like, I don't think
that's good. I don't want to displace
everyone from Gaza. I don't want to
displace everyone from Israel. So like,
what the [__] what do you do?
Look at us when you're talking to us,
soy pill.
I'm not happy, Destiny.
Not happy. As a Destiny fan, he's gone
off lately. He's been clever enough to
understand the issue, but him constantly
saying you're being bad faith is a
bigger red flag. Look, I get that
Destiny like doesn't know me, so he's
like not sure about most of what we
want. But I raised one earlier point I
forgot about that we want to see I think
from this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, around there
somewhere.
So, as part of Destiny's
petulant, impotent, flailing, winging,
crying, bitching about Hasan,
he decides to get on his [__] high
horse and start grandstanding about
about doxing and
bad personal behavior
from Hasan,
which obviously
to anyone who's even
remotely aware of anything Destiny's
done in the last several years
is a completely [__] absurd
uh uh
proposition that you may even struggle
to believe Destiny even attempted to
pass this off on a stream. But Soyboy
does pull him up on it a little bit, so
let's see. His personal behavior and
everything is deplorable is the word. I
get to that, but that's less bad for me
than the politics, which are like I
think are good destructive to dem Dude,
people hate on the silver lake and
they're totally filtered. Totally
filtered. But like that's not for an
intervention segment. I can see that. I
feel like
Wait, that is easy for someone
I'm not saying they're good. I'm saying
if I had to pick which of these things
is worse
the politics is going to be the more
destructive.
>> and proud let Destiny trout then Soyboy
go ahead. I don't know where that
statement came from. I'm not saying
they're good, right? If I were to say,
you know, this guy went to murder your
dog to cut his throat with say, well, I
wouldn't say that behavior is good. You
say, no, the behavior is deplorable. I
think Hasan is probably been responsible
for more harassment for anybody like in
the center left sphere than probably
than maybe any other single individual
Yeah, but Destiny, the thing I was about
to bring up was like whenever I appear
on screen with you, I get so much [__]
for all of the accusations against you,
the doc stuff, like any and all behavior
you participated in the past. And like
the thing is I'm willing to say
>> wait, wait, wait, real quick, who do you
think that comes from though?
It might be Hasan's community for sure,
but the It is. That's the point. You're
making my point. Yes, correct. But how
much of this is I don't know how much of
this is legitimate criticism or not, but
the my issue is I value your politics
and your movement far more than I do
potential accusations and how true any
of this is.
>> Destiny. I really believe in you. And so
when I hear the stuff of like oh, Hasan
is a horrible person and a lot of ways
and he deserves this. Like this is just
obviously true, but how much am I
willing to use this person in the same
way he's trying to use us to promote my
goals. And it's like if you could show
me that this is more harmful to my
movement, that's when I change my mind.
Why is Soy Pill always where he's got no
AC? Hasan Hasan, is that what you're
saying? It's not what we're saying that
like the personal behavior is bad in so
far as like there might be some
misgivings about how they conduct their
life or whatever. It's that Hasan will
directly attack people like in these
communities. Like would you still be
willing to work with me if you found out
that the mean messages you get when you
come on my stream are me messaging my
fan base in like another Discord saying
like hey, you guys need to go and harass
the [__] out of the Soy Pill. [__] you.
I honestly would. I honestly like that
>> Oh, yeah, he would never do that.
He would never do that. You have to
acknowledge when you have these
conversations that you are way outside
of the norm and that your
>> I know. I guess, but here's the thing,
Destiny, this already happens.
Most people will not Most people will
not tolerate that type of behavior.
That's an insane thing for the average
content creator, politician, or whatever
to deal with is another huge content
creator that is actively and I don't
mean like by way of having a
disagreement or whatever else, but is
directing their community to directly go
and harass another person. That's like a
That's a really out there behavior. No,
it is. Well, Wait. First of all, let me
let me wait I I no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait I really have to
address this. One, Destiny, I already
get so many DGers in my [__] DMs
telling me to [__] kill myself and
not because you told them to, by the
way. I know that's not it, but it's just
because of like the disagreements that
you and I might have. Not because not
because you told them to to Soy Pill,
but because he fosters and encourages
that behavior broadly.
And so they they apply it when they see
someone that they think Destiny's laid
out the conditions for them to apply it
to.
That's obviously why it's happening,
right? Destiny leads by example,
lays out exactly how bad these people
are and which types of people deserve
it. And Soy Pill falls in some of those
criteria because he's playing defense
for his own, he's playing defense for
lefties, he's on the podcast with Pisco.
He's being mean to Hutch, so he deserves
it. He deserves it. It's obviously the
case.
Who like tell me if this is not true.
Have you not doxed people on stream
before?
Yeah, people related to Jstark? Oh, well
well that makes it fine then. No, I
don't want to like justification is. My
point is that like
>> But Jstark, that guy is really scary and
intimidating and evil. So, I understand
why people related to Jstark you would
be you would be doxing.
That makes total sense now, actually. Or
just say less. Say less.
Now, that makes total sense.
Now, it's totally justified.
Me and me and I have so- suffered a
traumatic head injury. Injury. Me and I
have suffered a
severe head injury and
will never recover. Yeah, that makes
total sense.
You've done things that I would say, I
don't think that's okay. And I'm sure
you could find examples of me
>> You're Okay. But all I'm say- I'm not
trying to make these things equivalent.
What I'm saying is like if you're
saying, "Oh, well now I can never ever
ever do anything with this person
because it's a tacit endorsement of
everything they've ever done." Whether
that is No, that's not No one even said
that. No one was making that All right.
Well, okay. It's not about endorsing
behavior. It's about collaborating with
people that are actually trying to
destroy the other people in your space.
Yes.
Like that I like that's a very simple
thing. It's not like somebody said
>> Yeah, people related to Jstark, aka
people who got banned from DGG like 3
weeks ago. Exactly. I literally your
guys. Your guys, but they just don't
like you anymore.
Now you're doing the It's like they're
actively Hasan will actively try to
destroy people in the space. Like you
were on argue Well, not J Lion, but J
Lion Burns was on there. Okay, a guy who
we've all watched. I think we all are
personally friends with or at least I
Yeah, I'm on good terms with him, yeah.
Right? Hasan called this guy a war
tourist. Okay, a war tourist. Okay.
Dude, Wick sweating right now.
Wick literally [__] sweating hearing
this.
Who knows what I'm referring to? Like
three people, I guarantee.
People don't know this. Wick's first
introduction to like many people, to me
at least, certainly to most people in
Chud's Chud's community,
was him calling out Dylan Burns.
Uh it was him and this other guy. What
was his name? Mad Lad TV, I think was
his name.
Him and this other guy
calling out Dylan Burns saying literally
this, that Dylan Burns is a war tourist,
that he's just going there to profit and
and fetishize the suffering of
Ukrainians.
That's what they That's what Wick said.
Wick made that argument and he's going
to sit here like a [__] [__] Just
like, "Ooh. Ooh.
Ooh. Hope no one remembers. Hope no one
remembers."
All right, and was regularly roasting
him.
>> Okay, and what what the Why do you think
Dylan was on it?
What the Probably because Dylan had some
He wanted to talk about the Ukraine
issue because I was Yeah, I do you think
it's better that Dylan went on there and
promoted good messages despite the fact
that Hasan was on that panel? You just
totally said something what I brought up
though. I'm just saying that Hasan is
like what personally tried to destroy
using personal attack and not like these
are just political things.
>> thing is you're criticizing me for
potentially working with him, which was
being on a panel that he was on as well.
Dylan was as well. Dylan has even more
personal beef because of what you just
described and yet said, "You know what?
I think I can do more good introducing a
liberal pro-Ukraine message." Especially
with all the anti-Israel [__] in that
panel. It's like, "Hey, look, I'm
actually like talking about other
anti-war things that matter." And I
think he did more good doing that than
he would have if he said, "Oh, [__]
Hasan. Hasan was really mean to me. I'm
not going on this." Right?
>> want to make it clear. He was mean to
me.
Yeah, but Okay, sorry. I didn't mean to
[__] downplay it. You know what I
mean? Like maybe maybe I'm separating
myself from Destiny here, but I am not
criticizing you or Dylan for still
working with Progressive Victory. You do
what you think is best for your goals
and things like that.
>> And And Wick, to be clear, if you can
make me a compelling argument of why
this is ultimately that more
detrimental, I will stop doing it. Just
let me finish, right? That That's not
why I'm here today is I'm not here to
like deconvert you from progressive
victory. That's not That's not the
point.
>> Yeah, a lot is about progressive
victory. Anyway, I think we're about
done with it there. I think we're about
done with it there. I've got all the
good parts, really.